lo que tengo aquí es la lista de las
edades de los estudiantes de una clase y
lo que quiero explorar en este vídeo son
algunas formas distintas de representar
estos datos y ver si podemos responder
algunas preguntas sobre ellos y la
primera que podríamos revisar es la
tabla de frecuencias muy bien entonces
vamos a notar el nombre el nombre es la
tabla de frecuencias muy bien la tabla
de frecuencias y por supuesto la idea de
frecuencia es lo que va a hacer que
podamos deducir cómo hacer esta tablita
entonces para cada una de las edades
vamos a ver cuántos alumnos tienen esa
edad es decir vamos a ver cuál es su
frecuencia muy bien entonces vamos a
poner aquí la edad va a ser digamos
nuestra primera columna ok esta va a ser
nuestra primera columna y del lado
derecho vamos a poner la frecuencia muy
bien y quizás el término de frecuencia
te puede parecer raro pero esto
simplemente se refiere al número de
alumnos que tienen
muy bien ahora vamos a empezar con el
primero que es 5 verdad entonces digamos
vamos a pensar cuántos alumnos tienen 5
años muy bien entonces aquí podemos ver
que hay exactamente 2 alumnos muy bien
vámonos con ahora la edad de 6 vamos a
ver cuántos alumnos tienen 6 años y
revisamos en nuestra lista y solo hay un
alumno con seis años verdad ahora
vámonos con siete vamos a ver qué pasa
con siete
aquí tenemos uno dos tres y al final hay
otro verdad entonces tenemos cuatro
alumnos que tienen siete años veamos
ahora cuántos alumnos hay con ocho años
y si nos fijamos muy bien no tenemos
alumnos con ocho años verdad entonces
hay cero alumnos
vámonos ahora con nueve años y tenemos
uno
234 alumnos que tienen 9 años muy bien
vamos después con los alumnos que tienen
10 años y podemos ver que hay uno aquí
verdad tenemos un alumno verdad y a ver
qué pasa con los que tienen 11 años y
nos fijamos y en la lista no hay ningún
alumno que tenga 11 años tenemos 0 y
finalmente vamos a ver cuántos tienen 12
años quizás debería usar otro color
ok vamos a usar este de aquí 12 y 12
años tienen dos alumnos verdad dos
alumnos tienen 12 años ok entonces esta
es la tabla de frecuencias verdad es
esencialmente nos pone una categoría
digamos la edad y después nos nos
podríamos preguntar qué tan a menudo
ocurre que haya alumnos con cinco años
seis años diez años etcétera verdad eso
es lo que estamos poniendo en esta tabla
verdad es lo que hemos construido y por
supuesto tenemos la misma información
que está en la lista verdad si nosotros
por ejemplo empezábamos a poner cuántos
alumnos hay de cinco años pues aquí
aparecerían verdad quizás debería
ponerlo con ese mismo color
aquí aparecerían nuestros dos alumnos
con cinco años y ponemos cuántos alumnos
tienen seis años pues aquí aparecería
verdad tenemos exactamente la misma
información ahora la pregunta que
podríamos hacernos es cómo podríamos ver
esta información visualmente
para eso vamos a utilizar lo que se
conoce como la gráfica de puntos muy
bien vamos a construir la gráfica de
puntos
muy bien la gráfica de puntos y para
para hacer la gráfica de puntos voy a
hacer digamos un un eje algo así como un
eje muy bien y vamos a ir poniendo las
edades aquí estarán cinco años vamos a
hacerlo más grande cinco años seis años
siete años ocho años nueve años 10 años
11 años y 12 años muy bien aquí están
digamos los años y lo que vamos a ir
poniendo en esta gráfica es un punto por
cada alumno que tenga por ejemplo cinco
años entonces si vemos este ejemplo de
los cinco años tenemos dos alumnos
verdad entonces vamos a poner dos
puntitos cada uno representa a un alumno
que tiene cinco años vamos a ver qué
pasa con seis años sólo tenemos un
alumno verdad entonces ponemos solo un
puntito ahora con siete años tenemos
cuatro alumnos así que ponemos uno
2 3 y 4 puntitos verdad qué pasa con 8
años bueno con 8 años tenemos 0 así que
no ponemos puntitos pero con 9 años
tenemos nuevamente 4 verdad ponemos 1 2
3 y 4 muy bien con 10 años ahora tenemos
1 así que solo ponemos un puntito con 11
años no tenemos alumnos pero con 12 años
tenemos 2 entonces ponemos 12 puntitos
así que ya tenemos una lista inicial de
las edades de nuestros estudiantes en la
clase tenemos una tabla de frecuencias
verdad que construimos hace unos
momentos y además ya tenemos una forma
más visual de ver estos datos que es la
gráfica de puntos verdad son formas
distintas de ver exactamente la misma
información ahora podríamos intentar
responder algunas preguntas por ejemplo
cuál es la edad más frecuente verdad
entonces si nos fijamos en nuestra
gráfica de puntos podemos ver cuál es el
que tiene
puntitos asignados en sus edades verdad
entonces podemos ver que los que tienen
nueve años verdad tiene cuatro hay hay
cuatro estudiantes que tienen nueve años
y hay cuatro estudiantes que tienen
siete años estas son como las edades más
frecuentes también podríamos ver esto en
la tabla de frecuencias verdad nos
fijamos cuál es el que tiene el número
más grande en el lado de la frecuencia o
el número de alumnos verdad entonces por
ejemplo podríamos ver que aquí hay 21
aquí hay cuatro que es digamos un número
relativamente grande también aquí hay
cuatro y resultan ser los números más
grandes verdad entonces con esto
podríamos distinguir la respuesta a la
pregunta de cuál es la edad más
frecuente otra pregunta que podríamos
hacernos es cuál es el rango de los
datos verdad cuál es el rango
el rango y esencialmente el rango se
define como el número más grande de los
datos que tenemos y le restamos el
número más pequeño verdad por ejemplo
aquí en la tabla podríamos ver que el
número más grande es 12 y el número más
pequeño es 5 entonces nuestro rango
sería 12 menos 5 que es 7 verdad
entonces es el número más grande menos
el número más pequeño de digamos en este
caso de las edades y por supuesto
también podríamos verlo en las
frecuencias verdad en la tabla de
frecuencias aquí está el número más
grande y el número más pequeño y al
restar los nos da 7 otra pregunta más
por ejemplo podríamos preguntarnos cuál
cuántos alumnos tienen una edad mayor
que 9 que entonces déjenme anotarlo por
ejemplo cuántos alumnos tienen una edad
mayor que 9
mayor que 9 entonces podríamos irnos
directamente a nuestra gráfica de puntos
aquí está el 9 verdad y por supuesto es
el 9 no lo consideramos que vemos algo
estrictamente mayor que 9 y podemos
contar que hay 1 2 y 3 alumnos que
tienen una edad mayor que 9 entonces
tenemos 3 verdad nuevamente aquí también
en la tabla de frecuencias podríamos
verlo por ejemplo en aquí tenemos el 9
verdad aquí tenemos el 9 entonces nos
fijamos cuántos alumnos tienen una edad
mayor que 9 y tenemos 1 y otros 2 nos da
esto quizás en la lista original se
vuelve complicado verdad porque aquí
podríamos decir bueno aquí hay de 5 7 5
977 hay que revisar bastantes datos
hasta que encontremos un 10 verdad y
luego un 12 y luego un 2 entonces
podríamos decir que hay 3 entonces
realmente estas son dos formas muy
amigables para ver los datos esto en
este vídeo solo hicimos una presentación
de formas distintas de cómo apreciar los
datos y estos son las tablas de
frecuencia y la gráfica de puntos